hey leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
sieht vorstellung ich hab das einfach
mal schon alles hier eingegeben muss nur
noch hier reingehen steuerung frau und
dann ist ja auch schon das sieht der
wird mail vorgestellt bzw zugesendet von
dem user ferdinand fuchs der cee'd ist
41 32 7 148 der maya das ist ziemlich
eindeutig was man da sehen kann also
einfach mal umdrehen
tut mir leid dass ich jetzt dein
kommentar nicht einblenden konnte ich
plane gerade ein wenig viel ankommt 2.0
und ihr werdet schon sehen wie das in
zukunft ablaufen wird also erst bond
wieder auf einer einsamen insel ganz
alleine allerdings ist man nicht ganz
einsam denn man hat einen baum hinein
spaß also ich hab ich ja schon mal ein
sieg vorgestellt wo man einfach nur eine
insel hat nachrichten so wo man einfach
nur eine insel hat wo man dann quasi
hardcore bei leben spielen kann hier hat
man auch einfach nur der insel und nur
mit dem baum
aber man hat eine masche ruhm biom und
ich glaube ich möchte jetzt nicht lügen
aber ich glaube mushroom biome treten zu
einer wahrscheinlichkeit von unter 1
prozent auf jeden fall auf also ich hab
noch nie eins einfach so in einem spiel
gefunden außer ihm geber zieht eingeben
oder so wir sind halt ein paar grafik
bugs immer unter den filz nicht einfach
mal runter paar blöcke abbauen
dann gehen die weg und jetzt echt immens
viele kübel ist mir aufgefallen also der
zieht an sich total simpel einfach nur
eine zahlenkombination discounter hinten
auf einer insel und hier ist ein macho
biom allerdings ist hier auch nicht mehr
als eine million also ich bin ein
bisschen drumherum geflogen
und ich habe eigentlich nichts gesehen
an irgendwelche festland oder so ich mal
achtet mal das geht hier hinten zu ende
dass es zu ende da hinten dass es da zu
ende und da ist es halt auch zu ende von
daher weiß ich nicht ob das das einzige
ist also eigentlich nur ein überlebens
inseln hier noch einmal um bio ist ein
kleiner lover sie überleben wird hier
auf jeden fall schwierig man hat auf
jeden fall eine menge zu essen
allerdings ist es glaube ich schwer an
ärzte ranzukommen ich weiß nicht ob hier
etwas ist moment sind irgendwie ärzte
nicht so aber man hat halt ne menge von
diesem museum locken doch da ist kohle
gut da kann man sich wenigstens noch
wackeln machen
naja also wie schon gesagt man spontan
und einfach neben euch ist dann dieses
mushroom biom also wenn ihr das noch nie
gesehen habt oder das einfach mal sehen
wollt beziehungsweise entzieht volt wohl
direkt an
im spot an nehmt einfach diese sieht das
hatte ich ganz vergessen jetzt auch noch
eine kleine insel
naja das war erstmal die kürzeste sieht
vorstellung die ich bisher hatte bisher
aufgenommen hatte glaube ich die nächste
sieht vorstellung geht danach con 2.0
kommen ihr könnt ihr natürlich weiterhin
zieht sie die kommentare und per
nachricht schreiben am liebsten bitte
per kommentare dass es deutlich
einfacher für mich zu händeln und
vielleicht seid ihr in der nächsten zeit
vorstellung dann dabei schaue leute wenn
euch das video gefallen hat gibt ihm
einen daumen hoch und wenn ihr es
gefunden dann bitte einen daumen runter
geben jesse